mehr als fünf monate rosiger krieg in
der ukraine und auch heute wollen wir
uns dem militär situation im lande
ansehen und wir müssen uns immer mehr
ansehen die westlichen waffen denn die
westlichen waffen haben es in den
letzten tagen und wochen tatsächlich
geschafft hast nach den großen gebiets
gewinnen russlands im osten des landes
hier nämlich in der region lugansk und
auch in der region donetsk dort
tatsächlich die offensive jetzt zum
stehen gekommen ist ja weise seit
mehreren tagen keine vorsprünge mehr wir
wissen russland versucht sowie ans und
grammatik einzunehmen diese beiden
letzten großen städten in donetzk und
dort sehen mit der zeit keine vorsprünge
der russischen armee ja womit hat das
tun das hat vor allem mit den westlichen
waffen zu tun nämlich zum einen hier mit
der panzerhaubitze 2000 und das ist ganz
einmaliges material was wir sehen
nämlich von einer ganz besonderen
munition der sogenannten smart munition
hier sehen wir ein russisches fahrzeug
was an einem zerstörten dorf steht und
wir sehen gleich wie sich von oben etwas
offenes fahrzeug zu bewegt und zwar
relativ langsam wir sehen uns jetzt hier
da kommt es da kommt es hier sehen wir
etwas was ich darauf zu bewegt dann eine
explosion kurz vor dem fahrzeug und den
einschlag und dabei handelt es sich wie
gerade gesagt und so genannte smart
munition also munition die von der
deutschen panzerhaubitze 2000
zerschossen wird er verschlossen wird
die erst ungefähr 30 kilometer nach
vorne fliegt und dann eben so genanntes
abo missions also kleine unter munition
heraus lässt die an fallschirmen nochmal
genauer zielen können das gebiet
abscannen wir sehen uns hier das gebiet
abscannen wo ist der feind wo ist das
militärische fahrzeug und kurz davor
explodieren und dieses fahrzeug dann
vernichten das also die deutsche
panzerhaubitze 2000 hier im einsatz
jetzt im osten des landes und wir sehen
auch mit tödlicher wirkung hier sehen
wir eine weiteres westliches gerät was
gerade nach nachziehen sucht die ziele
wir sehen uns hier ganz gut sind
russische lkw die versteckt sind in
einem waldstück und das problem was die
russen jetzt haben sobald diese lkws
gesichtet werden wir sehen es hier
sobald die lkws gesichtet werden sind
die westlichen artillerie geschütze in
dem fall die m 777 aus den usa so genau
und so präzise dass sie in dem wald
versteckt diese russischen einheiten
auch treffen und zerstören können
insofern etwas was die ukraine vorher
überhaupt nicht konnte wozu sie nicht in
der lage war weil ihre ja ihre
geschützte eben sehr ungenau waren sowie
die russischen zu größten teil aus
sowjetischer produktion jetzt sehen wir
wie hier im wald die munition explodiert
und die russen die dort sich versteckt
haben dann dementsprechend ja auf jeden
fall nicht weiter kämpfen können
schlussendlich sind es aber nicht nur
militäreinheiten die die ukraine an
greift mit diesen westlichen waffen
sondern es sind auch immer mehr
munitionslager wir wissen dass in den
letzten 24 stunden 9 munitionslager weit
hinter der front zerstört wurden dabei
das wichtigste und größte hier in der
stadt nova kafka im süden des landes und
wir sehen uns gleich mal diese mega
explosion an die hier passiert das war
ein beschuss durch die amerikanische
heimat ein
raketen artillerie system was ungefähr
80 kilometer weit schießt und wir sehen
hier wie in der stadt nach dem beschuss
nach dem beschuss durch diese
amerikanische geschützt dort letzten
acht ein riesiges munitionslager in
brand geschossen wird und explodiert ja
das hat einen großen effekt wir merken
es ist hat einen effekt die russen haben
nicht mehr die munition sie können nicht
mehr so viel schießen wie sie es bisher
konnten und es fällt ihnen immer
schwieriger deshalb werden jetzt und
hier sind neue aufnahmen aus der
besetzung region luhansk deshalb werden
jetzt auch ältere waffen reaktiviert von
den russland behauptet sie haben die
überhaupt nicht mehr wir sehen hier
trotz
kabbalistische raketenwerfer etwa 100
kilometer reichweite von den hat
russland noch im april als mit einer
solchen rakete über 50 menschen in
kartons kein bahnhof getötet wurden
behauptet dass man die schon jahre nicht
mehr in betrieb hat wir sehen jetzt wie
russland immer mehr dieser ja dieser
sehr veralteten und sehr ungenauen
100 kilometer weiten raketensysteme hier
in die ukraine bewegt um eben irgendwie
auszugleichen was man verloren hat und
um eben mit diesen sehr alten sehr
ungenauen waffen dann ja ukrainische
städte in bis zu und einheiten bis zu
100 kilometer entfernung von der front
beschließen zu können